isolement et incertitudes pour l'avenir
les étudiants souffrent particulièrement
de cette crise
un étudiant sur six a d'ailleurs
décroché depuis la rentrée
d'où notre débat ce matin faut-il
rouvrir les universités pour ou contre
avec jeanne pêchons secrétaire national
de l'union des étudiants communistes et
pardonnez moi et son contrat des 100 kg
à bord avait supposé que l'ensemble des
français
je m'attends à une nourriture nécessaire
afin de pouvoir suivre les cours à
distance
on voit bien que ce n'est pas un caprice
les professeurs d'université qui sont
tout à fait calme n'ont pas forcément le
temps de pouvoir voir mener à la cour
alors même si beaucoup plus de temps
pour pour les cours à distance
il ya une immense urgence de réouvrir
les universités c'est quand même près
même plus de la moitié des enseignements
et des examens qui ont été faites à
distance donc ça ça touche la formation
la qualité de notre formation excusez
moi ça touche la valeur de nos diplômes
donc donc clairement il faut ré ouvrir
les cyber cité dès début janvier avec
des priorités à donner à certains
groupes d'étudiants notamment ses
premières années de licence et puis à
espérer un retour à la normale avec en
fonction des conditions sanitaires début
février
[Musique]
ces chercheurs
si on attend de pouvoir exercer leur
métier à savoir enseigner qui sont
arrivés ils sont pas arrivés en première
position au concours recrutons une
personne est nécessaire
ouvrant les locaux ouvrent les portes de
l'université à prendre le pouvoir et
permettait à manchester de tous je pense
que c'est clairement maintenant et
peut-être même avant vendredi ou en tout
cas avant noël qu'on devrait avoir
maintenant une concertation avec le
ministère pour qu'on puisse leur faire
remonter des informations sur comment
ont été organisés les réussites les
échecs de ses examens de ces différents
examens présentiel dans l'est dans les
universités pour pouvoir justement
réfléchir aux conditions de la rentrée
de la rentrée 2021 j'aimerais avoir
l'avis de ma collègue sur sur ses
camarades de lutte qui dans beaucoup de
facultés de france demandent des
moyennes améliorable demande des 10 pour
tous et ce sont des mesures comme celle
ci si elles sont appliquées dans les
universités françaises qui achèveront
définitivement l'université française
justement l'enseignement supérieur
français et les diplômes des 2 millions
700 mille étudiants que leur travail
soit sanctionné justement que leur
mérite soit reconnu et qu' il puisse
qu'il puisse avoir un diplôme qu'ils
valent quelque chose sur leur sur leurs
marques sur le sur le marché du travail
quand ils y arriveront à la question la
question
je requiers voire 15 ou 10 je pense que
c'est pas forcément là la question à se
poser c'est de permettre à chacun de
pouvoir suivre la formation de son choix
de permettre voilà de pouvoir poursuivre
ses études pour former la toute une
génération pour accomplir les
défilements et ça c'est la question
on va se poser